foreign
to today's Quantum colloquium so it's a
pleasure to have um Yun Chao Liu he's
our very own from UC Berkeley so yunchao
is a PhD student in working with me and
he um he has already done a lot of very
interesting work in Quantum benchmarking
of course in the complexity of you know
complexity of random circuit sampling uh
Quantum benchmarking using random
circuit sampling and also on the
learning of you know learning Quantum
circuits so yunchao will talk about the
polynomial Quantum algorithm for noisy
random circuit sampling so yuncha
okay
great thanks so much so it's my pleasure
to talk about my recent work on a
polynomial time classical algorithm for
noisy random circuit sampling
this is Joint work with Dorita haronov
at Hebrew University chewing God Harvard
and Zach Landau mesh was running from UC
Berkeley
so in 2019 Google performed a Quantum
Supremacy experiment and claimed a
Quantum breakthrough that could change
computing
so the experiment is called random
circuit sampling and it has three steps
first we use current noisy intermediate
scale Quantum devices to sample from a
random Quantum circuit
and second because the device is very
noisy and far from perfect we use a
statistical test to evaluate how good
the device is performing
and finally we claim that the same
performance from the statistical test
cannot be achieved classically
so later this experiment has been
replicated by usdc and these experiments
really represent a great advance in
physics experiments
and from the computers computer science
perspective
they represent a great advanced in
exploring
the high complexity regime of quantum
mechanics
so in this talk we will discuss recent
progress understanding the computational
complexity of RCs
so this talk consists of four parts
we will first give an overview of RCs
and our main results and then we will
discuss prior work on the computational
complexity of RCs
and next we will give a proof sketch and
finally give some discussion and
conclusions
so let's start with the first part
overview of RCs and our main results
so the motivation of this work comes
from the extended Church touring thesis
formulated by Bernstein wazirani
it says that any reasonable model of
computation can be efficiently simulated
on a probabilistic turing machine
so here efficient refers to polynomial
time
of course this is expected to be
evaluated by scalable for tolerance
Quantum computing
and one of the motivations for Quantum
Supremacy is to make this happen sooner
so the goal is to give an experimental
violation of the expenditure string
thesis using noisy intermediate scale
Quantum devices
and there are really two aspects of this
goal
the first aspect is computational
complexity
where the main question is does the
model of noisy random circuit sampling
well it's the extended three instances
in the asymptotic sense
the second aspect is finite science
experiments
where the main question is does current
53 to 60 qubit experiments take a lot of
resources meaning time and gpus
to simulate classically
so in this talk we will mainly focus on
computational complexity
but we will also briefly discuss finite
size experiments
so here's the model of RCs experiments
so we have a random Quantum circuit
shown on the right hand side
and each white box indicates a
independently sampled random two Cubit
gates from a certain distribution
and there is also a noise in the circuit
where at each step each qubit is subject
to a arbitrally small constant amount of
noise so this is our theoretical model
and
the experiment is performed as follows
first we sample a random circuit looks
like this on N qubits with steps d
here we will want D to be at least log n
to satisfy a condition called
anti-concentration which says that
output distribution of the random
circuit
should be
sufficiently well widespread for
statistical purposes
and next we'll fix this circuit and
implement it on the device many times
and obtain M samples from this noisy
output distribution denoted by P tilde
next after collecting these M samples we
will compute a statistical measure which
is simply a function of the circuit as
well as the m
-bit strings
so in general this takes exponential
time
and later we will discuss how to deal
with this
exponential time for statistical
verification in actual experiments
and finally we repeat about procedure
for a few independent random circuits
okay so here is our main results
consider a noisy RCS experiment which
collects M samples that looks like this
so here we will do the experiment of
favor and ignore the time used for
classical verification
so we will only count the time
in the experiment to collect these and
samples which of course is proportional
to m
so we give a algorithm that can also
generate M samples that looks like this
and this takes poly and time
so this could be slower than the
experiment but not exponentially slower
moreover
the output distribution of our algorithm
is so close to the output distribution
of the noisy experiments that no
statistical paths can tell the
difference between the two
okay so here is the detailed statement
of the theorem
there is a classical algorithm that
input a random circuit C are in qubits
I'll put a sample from a distribution
that is Epsilon close to the noisy
distribution in total variation distance
with success probability at least 99
over the choice of C
in time poly and one or Epsilon
so this result has some assumptions
which are anti-concentration and
sufficient Randomness in the gate set
so later we will discuss them in more
detail
and also this improves the previously
known result of Garland one in 2018
which is n to the power of all log 1
over Epsilon
so roughly speaking this Improvement is
important because we will see that we
want to choose Epsilon to be very very
small
so next we will discuss how to
understand the results and in particular
we will show how to use this serum to
get the claim that we just showed in the
picture
so the main significance of this result
comes from comparing classical
simulation and Quantum experiments
and this is related to a very simple
fact which is consider two given
probability distributions
and they cannot be distinguished by any
statistical test
on M samples say with probability of 51
if they are very close to a very close
in total Direction distance and the
closeness is roughly
0.01 over m
and therefore we can choose Epsilon to
be this target
and plug it into the serum statement and
resulted in a running time of poly n and
M
to guarantee indistinguishability
in other words our result says that the
running time of our algorithm is at most
a polynomial in the runtime of the
experiments in order to be statistically
indistinguishable from the experiments
and of course we should point out that
currently the running time of our
algorithm is Not Practical it's roughly
m to the power of one or gamma where
gamma is the noise per case and
therefore this results do not directly
address finite science experiments
so now having understood the results
the next thing to do is to understand
the scaling of M
with respect to with respect to the size
of the circuit
in particular we will discuss the row of
circuit apps
so here the situation is that
the experiment is very noisy and we need
to collect enough samples to detect a
non-trivial Quantum signal from the
experiment
so here we have this axis and the
distance on this axis indicates the
distance between probability
distributions
so we have the uniform Distribution on
on one end
and the ideal output distribution of the
random circuit is far from uniform on
the other end
so since we have a small amount of noise
brigades the output distribution of a
noisy random circuit sampling experiment
will be will in fact be exponentially
close to uniform in total variation
distance
in circuit depth
so the opposite distribution of noisy
RCS is 2 to the minus Theta D equals to
uniform
as a result
the experiment needs to collect at least
two to the D samples
because otherwise we cannot even tell
the difference between the experiment
and the uniform
this means that in general both
experiments and our algorithm have run
into an exponential in circuit apps
so this means that using a large circuit
depth in RCS is Not Practical for both
the experiments and our algorithm
however there is a specifically
interesting
parameter in this regime which is Theta
log in depth
so as we have discussed earlier
anti-concentration is a central
assumption for both experiments and our
algorithm and that needs at least login
depths
on the other hand
we want the experiment to have
polynomial sample complexity
and this means that the circuit depth
should we should be at most login
therefore this means that Theta login
depths is actually a sweet spot for
scalable Quantum Supremacy experiments
as recognized by Dachshund
so this is the regime where
the experiment is fully scalable and
both experiments and our algorithm have
running time that is polynomial in the
number of qubits
so this is the situation of this regime
the noisy RCS distribution is one or
probably far from uniform with some
fixed constant C here
and then
our algorithm can sample from a
distribution that is
obviously one or poly Coast close to
noisy RCs
in time polynomial in number of qubits
in the meantime
it is conjectured to be hard to sample
from a distribution that is close to the
ideal RCS distribution without noise
okay so this finishes the description of
our results
and to put these results into context
next we will discuss power work on the
computational complexity of RCs
so there are two main genres of Prior
work on computational complexity the
first genre is is what we call as ideal
RCs
so here the input is just a random
Quantum circuit and we want to sample
from the output distribution of this
circuit and there are no noise in the in
the definition of these Quantum circuits
so here the goal is to prove that it is
hard to sample from a distribution that
is Epsilon close to the ideal
distribution
of this random circuit in total
variation distance
so by known reductions given by
stockmeier and errors and archipel
if we assume anti-concentration then it
suffices to show
something about Computing the output
probability of this random circuit
in particular we want to show that it is
sharply hard to compute
the output probability of this random
circuit within additive error Epsilon
over 2 to the n
so roughly speaking this just comes from
the fact that we want to get absolute
close in total variation distance and
therefore on average we want each output
probability to be Epsilon over 2 to the
N cost
okay so this has been the goal for a
line of work
and currently we cannot prove this
statement but we can prove a statement
with uh
smaller robustness in the additive error
in particular if we consider a random
circuit sampling
input with encubus and M Gates
where m is roughly n times d
then the early result of BF and V and
Mozart
showed
averages hardness with some small
additive error
with the large exponents
and later
you might work with Adam boland's Bill
femmerman Jeff London together with
kmm21 we improve this result to
exponential in minus M Times log m
and later
in this year krobe removed the log
factor and improve it to to the minus om
and of course this still falls short
from achieving the goal which is Epsilon
over 2 to the n
however
here I should also say that there are
several known battery results as
indicated by this red mark which says
that with the type of techniques that we
have been using for approving these
results it's unlikely that we can
eventually reach the goal
so
that's roughly the picture in the ideal
regime
on the other hand the second genre of
Prior work on computer complexity of RCs
is in the high noise regime
so here
we want to look at the different
situation which is instead of being
close to the output distribution of
Ideal RCS internal Direction distance
actual experiments actually only achieve
a tiny correlation with the ideal Auto
distribution due to noise
and this is a simple uh simply a
consequence of the fact that the noisy
distribution converges to uniform
extensually quickly in depth
however
we want to show that this is still hard
classically
because this is the regime that is
relevant to actual experiments
so as an example let's see what Google
did in their experiments
so given I'm samples from the device
what Google did is to calculate this
specific
statistical measure called linear
constantropy
which is a simple linear function of the
ideal output probability of these
samples collected from the device
so let's try to understand this quantity
a little bit
in expectation if we are not doing
anything non-trivial if we are just
sampling from the uniform distribution
then this quantity equals to zero
on the other hand if the experiment is
perfect meaning that the sample is
actually from the ideal distribution
then this quality is related to the
second moment of the
ideal RCs
which is something that is larger than
zero
so here the overall intuition is that if
the experimental distribution is more
correlated with the ideal RCS
distribution
then this statistical test
tends to be larger
and therefore it can be used as a
benchmark of the experiments
okay
so as a quick summary in expectation the
xcb is roughly the inner product between
the two distributions and it equals to
zero when the experiment is uniform and
it equals to one when the experiment is
perfect and this is also related to
anti-concentration
okay but an issue here is that
as we have mentioned in the beginning
even with this very simple statistical
task it is still hard to estimate
because
it requires Computing these ideal output
probabilities which takes two to the end
time in general
however
there are ways to compute these things
at small sizes and then heuristically
extrapolate to large size
and there's there has been some
arguments
showing that this heuristic
extrapolation works well above login
depths
and therefore this is what Google did
and they concluded that their
experiments on 53 qubits and
that's 20 achieves an xcb of 0.002
and indeed this is only a tiny
correlation with the ideal RCS
distribution
okay
so now the issue is clear
we want to focus on the noisy regime and
we want to show that even the tiny xcb
achieved in experiments is still hard to
achieve tasks
so how do we do this
in 2019 erinson Gunn formulated a
conjecture called x-class
and this conjecture says that even a
tiny correlation of order 2 to the minus
n with the ideal RCS distribution it's
still hard to achieve classically
so this is very similar to the previous
conjecture of Aaron Zen Chen in 2016
called quas
which supports the hardness of a
different statistical task called heavy
output generation
so the reason that they need to
conjecture this very strong parameter of
water to the minus sun was because
this was necessary to support the
hardness of tiny xdb due to the fact
that the reduction has an overhead
so overall
this provided a way to curiously argue
that even the virus very small xcb
achieved the actual experiments was
still a classically hard task
and indeed this this conjecture has been
reasonable
and therefore it provides the evidence
of high complexity in the noisy regime
that we needed
however
last year the recent work of galatel
cast doubt on these arguments
specifically it shows that actually
a correlation of 2 to the minus D can be
achieved classically
and since in experiments we use a
circuit apps that is much smaller
compared to the number of qubits this
sort of refused the previous conjecture
however there are two points that is
unaddressed by this work
because even if the original strong
conjectures
are false there could still be a weaker
conjecture that still supports the
hardness of noisy experiments
and furthermore this result only
specifically targets the xcb test
and the other statistical tests could
still be hard to achieve classically for
example this result doesn't say anything
about the heavy output generation test
but overall this works really reopens
the question of
is there high complexity in noisy RCS
experiments
and our work address this question by
showing that no statistical tasks can
distinguish between the experiment with
M samples
and our
polyantine algorithm
okay
so having introduced the prior works on
RCs
here's a brief summary
so first we show that the running time
of our algorithm is at most polynomial
in the running time of the experiments
in order to be indistinguishable from
the experiments
and in particular at Theta log and depth
both the experiments and our algorithm
have polynomial runtime in the number of
qubits
So based down the above two statements
we come to the conclusion that noisy RCS
cannot be the basis of a scalable
experimental violation of the extended
Church twin theaters
and here this provides the motivation
that
it's really an exciting time to start
developing new proposals for near-term
Quantum computational Advantage with a
better complexity Foundation
such as we can try to
to practical implementation of
cryptographic proof of quantities
protocols
and of course
our result is conditioned on the
assumptions that we make and we will
discuss them in detail later
okay
so next let's temporarily deviate from
complexity Theory and briefly discuss
recent progress on practical simulation
of RCs experiments
so as we introduced earlier xcb is the
statistical test that's reports a number
between 0 and 1.
in 2019 Google achieved xcb of 0.2
percent
and based on the largest uh based on the
best simulation algorithm
they estimated that it would take 10 000
years classically to achieve the same
xcb with the largest supercomputer
however
it turns out that since then a lot of
progress has been made with practical
tensor Network algorithms
and this leads to the result last year
by panchang Zhang which used Brute Force
tensor Network simulation to achieve the
same xcb using 500 gpus in 15 hours
however from the Practical perspective
this is really not the end of story
because
this Brute Force algorithms
are inherently exponential time and
therefore they become impractical even
if the system size just slightly
increased by a few qubits
in particular the largest RCS experiment
currently on 60 cubits by usdc has not
been challenged by Costco's simulation
algorithm
and of course on the other hand there
has also been effort to try to develop
efficient algorithms to achieve the same
performance
in particular
the algorithm of God health is scalable
with system size
but it currently achieves 10 percent of
the xcp of Google's experiments
so here an interesting question is
can we develop practical implementations
of our algorithm that achieves a good
performance
so for now it is too early for us to
speculate about
the outcome of this
okay
so that's the situation with practical
simulation
and next let's spend some time to
understand the proof
so we will start with an overview of the
power arguments
to give evidence of high complexity in
the noisy regime
in particular the intuition behind
errands and guns conjecture is the final
pass integral which is this simple
formula
so let's consider a Quantum circuit C
equals u d blah blah U2 U1 so each UI
represents a layer of two cubic Gates
so the final pass integral is this
simple equation
that is simply a fact of inserting the
computational basis in in between each
each of the layers
so on the left hand side we have this
output output amplitude of the quantum
circuit
and on the right hand side we have this
huge sum
there are many many terms
um in this huge sum and each term is a
product of small transition amplitudes
that are complex numbers
so the intuition of parents and gun is
the following
so we know that
each term on the right hand side which
we call final pass they contribute
equally on average since we have a
random circuit
and there are many many paths in total
roughly 2 to the N times d
and therefore if we have a efficient
classical algorithm we can only sum over
polient of these parts
and
since that's such a very small fraction
of the total amount of tax this only
gets an exponentially small correlation
with the ideal
output distribution
and therefore they can lecture that no
classical algorithm country better than
one or two today in correlation with the
ideal RCs
Okay so
essentially our algorithm actually looks
very similar to this except that we use
a different basis
so it turns out that we just take
exactly the same algorithm find them has
integral
which we already know shouldn't work for
simulating random circuits
but
it turns out that it actually works if
we change to a different basis
where we used actually the poly basis
so here is the it's a diagram that shows
an example of the
Phantom passing tool
so on the left hand side we have this
Quantum circuit and we insert a
particular computational basis elements
in between these layers and this
specifies a particular final path
and we know that the contribution of
these paths are uniform
so on the right hand side shows our
algorithm the poly passing scroll and
this algorithm and this diagram shows a
specific poly path
where we can see that
in each layer we insert
an elements from the poly operators
okay so there are two main ideas behind
this algorithm that makes it work
the first idea is that in the poly in
the poly basis these parts are actually
highly non-uniform
and therefore we can actually order them
by importance and then only consider the
most important task
so as we remarked here due to noise the
contribution of a polypath actually
decays accidentally with the number of
non-identities
the number of X y's and Z's in this
diagram
and the second main idea is to design
efficient algorithms to calculate those
important paths
so
the algorithm uses the unitarity
constraints that we highlighted here in
the yellow
which says that in the polypath
the identity operator can only go to the
identity operator
and therefore
the algorithm can be efficient enough to
achieve the desired approximation error
in polynomial time
and next we will discuss both of these
new ideas in detail
so let's start with the first main idea
non-uniformity of poly paths
so the idea is that let's consider the
final enhance integral in the poly or
Fourier basis
then the contribution of a low weight
pass is much higher than a highway pass
due to noise so here weight just means
the hanging weight of the poly pass
which is the number of non-identities
in the past
so to understand these sentence we will
need to specify what we exactly mean by
a polypas
and this involves two steps
the first step is to switch from Vector
basis to operator basis
that is instead of thinking about a
Quantum circuit as applying unitary
matrices to vectors
we think of them as applying unitary
channels to density matrices
and the second step is to decompose the
density Matrix
at each layer in the poly basis
using the fact that the poly operators I
complete basis for matrices
so now we can decompose the density
Matrix as a linear combination of polio
operators with real coefficients
and then we can just think about
evolving poly operators and combining
all of these transition amplitudes
so let's consider this by analogy
in the vector basis we can think of a
unitary Matrix as might be a snapping a
computational basis element I to J
and the transition amplitude for this
mapping is
uh
broadcast J UI which is a complex number
so in the poly basis we want to apply
unitary channels to poly matrices and
consider the transition amplitude so in
this case the transition amplitude from
SI to SJ whereas and SJ are polyoplers
equals to this quantity the trace of SJ
times usiu dagger
in particular you as Au dagger is the
evolution of the poly operator and the
unitary Channel and then this Trace is
simply a unit product between SJ and
this operator
so this is just an analogy of this
Vector basis transition amplitude
okay so having this now we can write
down the formula which we refer to as
poly pass integral
it's very similar to The Standard
Finance integral with several
differences
so on the left hand side we have the
amplitude Square which is the output
probability of the quantum circuit
instead of uh so this is a positive real
number instead of being a complex number
independent has integral
on the on the right hand side we still
have this giant huge sum of
poly paths and each polypath is a
product of these real transition
amplitudes
and therefore this right hand side is
just a giant sum of real numbers which
can be both positive and negative in
instead of being complex numbers
and we denote these polypath by
sum over s f c and s
so as it's just a configuration of the
polypath that we show earlier in the
diagram
okay
so with this
the idea becomes clear
in particular if we consider
depolarizing noise in the poly basis it
has this simple form of mapping identity
to Identity
and no identity poly to no identity poly
with a coefficient one minus gamma where
gamma is the strength of the noise
so having this we can write down the
poly pass integral as the following
so for a Quantum circuit see
the polypas integral is just saying that
we can decompose the output probability
of the column circuit c as a giant sum
of the poly path
and then
if we add noise into this circuit the
left hand side becomes the output
distribution of the noisy circuit
and the right hand side is a related
related
um poly path integral
where the contribution of a polypath in
the noisy circuit decays exponentially
with its Heming weight
so here the absolute value of s is
defined as the Hamming rate of s
so now the algorithm is very simple
we just compute this truncated version
of the noisy output distribution
so here we have this sum over S one
minus gamma to the power of s times the
poly path except that we only sum over
over those
polypaths that have low Heming weight up
to some parameter l
and it turns out that it suffices to
choose l equals o log one over Epsilon
to achieve the desired
approximation error
okay
so the claim that we can just choose l
equals o log 1 over Epsilon to achieve
the desired total variation distance
Epsilon it's non-trivial
because as we have discussed earlier
each of these terms in the poly path
integral FCS they can be both positive
and negative real numbers
and therefore it's not obvious that the
more paths we calculate the better
performance it will get
however it turns out that this is the
case and the proof for this bounce uses
two properties of random circuits
the first property is what we call
orthogonality this is saying that on
average over random circuits
the product of two polypats equals zero
when the polypath is different
and the second property is called
anti-concentration which is saying that
on average over random circuit the
second moment of the probability of the
ideal probability distribution is small
so having these two properties we can
just give a very simple
proof sketch of this claim
so the proof is that we can use cozy
Schwarz to convert the
L1 distance which is what we want to
bounce to L2 distance
and that becomes a giant Square
and then we can use orthogonality to
kill all the cross terms which
can transfers this giant square into a
sum of squares of small terms and then
we can show that this sum of square can
be bounded using anti-concentration
okay so this is how to get the desired
approximation error with the algorithm
and then it only remains to show that
how much time do we need to get this
approximation
and this brings to the second idea
which is efficient enumeration of poly
paths
so here the key observation is unitarity
which are very simple fact saying that
if we consider unit 3 as a Quantum
Channel
then it can only map identity to
Identity poly and no identity to an
identity
so let's consider this by analogy if we
can say a unitary Matrix you
then the transition amplitudes broadcast
GUI
this in general can be a non-zero
complex number for any infj
on the other hand if we consider the
transition amplitudes in the poly basis
the trace of SJ usiu dagger this quality
can only be non-zero when both s and SJ
are the Identity or both of them are
non-identity
and of course this means that a public
pass only contributes a non-zero value
if it satisfy this constraint everywhere
in the circuits
so clearly for our classical simulation
algorithm we only need to worry about
those polypaths that are non-zero and
therefore this constraints
dramatically reduces the computational
complexity of the time in order to
calculate all these relevant poly paths
in particular
the inside we used to reduce the time
is called continuity which is saying
that if we look at the poly path then
the configuration of a layer
of the polypath in a certain layer
cannot deviate Too Much from the
previous layer so here is an example
let's consider the poly paths in these
two layers of the circuit
so this is a valid poly pass which which
could be non-zero and we can clearly see
that it needs to respect this constraint
highlighted in the red circle where if
we have identity in the bottom layer
then the top layer is forced to also be
identity
so if the bottom layer is not identity
for some gates
such as this RX then the top layer can
be anything
except either the identity
so this combinatorial constraints allows
us to design a enumeration algorithm
that calculates all of the non-zero
polypats below with L in time 2 to the L
so this happens to be good enough
because L equals log one or Epsilon and
therefore 2 to the L equals poly one
over Epsilon
so this completes the proof of the
algorithm
okay
so now uh we will conclude with some
discussions
the first thing is to discuss the
assumptions in our main results
so we have just saw that we have these
two key assumptions when bounding the
truncation error anti-concentration and
orthogonality so let's look into them
anti-concentration says that the second
moment of the output probability of the
ideal RCS is small
and this statement has been proven for
certain architectures and it's believed
to hold above log depths for General
architectures
and of course here the question is
what about sub logarithmic depths random
circuits
so clearly our result is not applicable
applicable in this regime but there are
a few things we can say about this
the first thing is that
theoretically it is even unclear if
ideal random check is something below
log depths is hard or not
due to the fact that we don't have
anti-concentration and therefore
the line of work that we discussed for
our drcs doesn't really apply
an example here is that nap at all
showed that showed that ideal random
circuit sampling in two-dimensional
lattices with very small depths below
some constant is classical similable
even without noise in the gates
and the second point is that existing
random Circuit Assembly experiments
relies on product homos for the
statistical benchmarking this is
actually even stronger than the
concentration
so so far all of the experiments
needs anti-concentration to in order to
perform the statistical statistical
tests
okay so the next uh assumption in our
main result is Randomness in the gate
set
where we assume that the gift set is
closed under random polygates and in
particular this is used
to imply orthogonality which we just
show
in the proof
so this statement is
quite mild for example it holds for high
random typically Gates or a fixed quick
weight gate with high random Syncopy
Gates
of course here the question is what
about less random git sets
so there are a few things we can say
about this
the first thing is that we need at least
some Randomness in the circuit
since of course we are by definition we
are doing random circuit sampling so we
need some Randomness in the gates for
example to produce the signatures of
random circuits such as portal Thomas
and this uh second point is that
currently we do not know if the
environment result probably works for
Google and ustcc sets because they
violates the above condition
but it works very closely related gate
set where we just insert random Z
rotations on top of Google and usdc
skitsap
okay so this uh concludes the
discussions on the assumptions here are
main results
and finally let's give some conclusions
so the conclusions of this talk is that
RCS is a really exciting experiment with
multiple aspects
first it is a very good Benchmark for
Quantum devices
because it is a clear it represents a
clear metric to evaluate the
combinational power of our current noisy
Quantum devices
and second
the current back and forth with
classical spoofing algorithms they
really inspired continued improvements
of quantum devices
so this back and forth is really a
healthy development in our field
in the meantime there are also several
issues with scaling up RCs for
potentially larger devices in the future
the first issue is that theoretically we
give strong negative evidence for RCS as
a scalable experimental violation of the
extended structuring diseases
and then practically there is also the
issue of it becomes harder to perform
verification as the system size gets
bigger even with these heuristic methods
that we currently have
so this gives motivation to really start
developing new proposals for near-term
Quantum computational Advantage with a
better complexity Foundation
and hopefully hopefully also efficient
verification
and one interesting thing to do is to
think about how much resource in terms
of qubits and gate hours are needed for
cryptographic proof of quantities
protocols
and finally let me end with some high
level remarks
so at this point if we look back
in into the history it's clear that RCS
is clear that the best thing about RCS
and Quantum Supremacy experiments is
that they provided a clear Target for
the field to achieve
and as a result this actually motivated
a giant leap in the development of
larger and better Quantum devices
so this is really a great thing so why
don't we try to do this again with the
next challenge problem
on the future devices
in particular
the accumulated experimental advances
and the theoretical understanding in
complexity theory that we have learned
from RCS provides the foundation for the
next challenge problem for the next
generation of near-term quantum devices
okay and that's all I want to say thank
you
thank you
great uh thank you Angel
um
maybe we had time for a few questions uh
before we set up the panel so
uh if anybody wants to
wants to
ask a question uh
maybe we can you know you can raise your
hands or or
um or just speak up okay I see uh venkat
would you like to unmute
um sure um yeah thanks to Joe a really
nice talk
um I had two questions actually
um one sort of Technical and one little
more just trying to understand the layer
of the land based on your final summary
the first question was so your I guess
your algorithm has an exponent of one
over gamma where is where the gamma is
the noise rate and I guess that sort of
makes sense because if it's more noisy
it becomes easier to simulate but
um can you say where that dependence
comes from in your algorithm
all right so maybe you said that name I
missed it sorry
Okay so
yeah and it essentially comes from here
when Bound in the transition error
because we can see that here is an
exponential decay with respect to the
hanging weights but the exponents is
sort of so this is roughly e to the
minus gamma times s
so if we choose some specific truncation
parameter
in order to achieve the desired
approximation hour it naturally have a
one hour gamma inside of this uh Factor
but of course this is a sort of a
theoretical upper bound and
the the it doesn't necessarily mean that
this is the optimal running time and
there's there's potentially room for
improvements
um great and I guess the second question
was a little more high level I guess
there is this sort of Chase between
doing things with this nisq model like
the circuit sampling and then trying to
then also achieve it with classical
things
I mean is is it conceivable that maybe
the actual Supremacy will be exhibited
once you have some error correction
built in so you can go beyond this model
or do you think already in the nisq
there should be some demonstration
yeah so uh I think that's really up for
discussion at this point because
for example if we want to do this
cryptographic proof of economies which
is a very well-funded protocol
and already we all only need to sort of
go beyond certain security parameters so
it's sort of still a finite science
problem and whether we can actually do
it on maybe near future devices it's
really up for
a full discussion
okay thanks
and sevak
[Music]
yeah hi uh Junction really great to talk
and I love the work
um so I just want to ask in a very
simple high-level question which is that
you mentioned there's this uniform gauge
set assumption and how it doesn't
actually break as far as you can tell
like the Google experiments in utsc for
example and so the simple question is I
mean the work
very explicitly says you know we should
not use rcds as a foundation for noisy
or Cs and yet uh you know this slide
says that you haven't broken the Google
experiment so what should I take out of
this like
is there still hope for RCs at least for
non um
non-uniformly random gate sets are the
Google is the Google approach broken in
some sense or not right
yeah of course uh strictly speaking we
cannot say anything about exactly
those get sets used in those experiments
but really it's hard to believe that
there could be a huge difference in
complexity between different random gate
sets
uh part of that evidence comes from this
statement where
this random zero rotation is sort of a
simple change on top of the gate set and
it makes it satisfy the
assumption so at this point I think it's
really
interesting to further investigate
whether this uh this condition in our
result is really
artifact of the proof or it is
fundamental so it's not complete
completely clear yet although one would
expect that it's not fundamental
okay so I should take it as you know
that the inspiration of the random Z
rotations is your way of saying okay you
strongly believe but RCS really is
broken in the noisy regime as far as
Supremacy is concerned in the asymptotic
sense yes yes exactly of course good
yeah but um for like extended Church
during thesis that is the sense we care
about I suppose in some sense right
yeah
so yeah okay cool thank you
any other questions so venkat you
already uh do you
okay great okay so
um I think there was a there was a
question the Q a
um oh yeah let me address the apply
anything about simulation okay go ahead
oh shooting is typing an answer okay so
Okay so
of course the currently this doesn't say
anything about the simulation of
arbitrary Quantum circuits because
in particular
uh the relevant part is that this Bond
requires Randomness in a gate set you
can see that all of these statements has
average over Quantum circuits in front
of them
so clearly
um
yeah so this doesn't directly say
anything about arbitrary Quantum
circuits although it's interesting to
further
investigate maybe what kind of quantum
circuits can this algorithm work and
what what kind of service does it not
work
okay so the second question is what
would be a good potential challenge
problem for next X devices
uh one thing is what I mentioned as the
cryptographic performance but of course
it would be very interesting to come up
with something in between because that
still seems a bit far from the things
the devices we have right now so maybe
some combination of RCs with some some
other things to make it with uh have a
better complexity Foundation
and second would your results still hold
if one were to replace total variation
Distance by water sign type distances
so final results the real main
motivation is to guarantee statistical
interesting English distinguishability
and for that purpose total variation
distance is the right distance
the other things may not be directly
relevant for a statistical verification
okay great um so maybe um if you stop
sharing your slides you can move on to
the panel at this point
so
um
okay great well welcome everyone to the
the panel uh so it's um you know as you
can see it's a it's a really fantastic
panel because
um it's sort of a who's who in in random
circuit sampling uh starting with Scott
who of course you all know about and
he's um you know uh I I don't need to
say that um he's he's done more about
Quantum Supremacy than anybody else that
I that I know of uh uh there's um uh
Adam buland who's uh who's on the
faculty at Stanford and of course in
addition to the work he's done on the
complexity of uh of random circuit
sampling he's also you know he's his
work sort of uh asks this question what
is complexity Theory illuminate for us
in terms of physics you know quantum
gravity Etc
and then third your bike so who you've
seen on on these panels many times he's
the chief scientist that um at uh at
Google and and is one of the main
theoreticians dealing with these
questions about about random circuit
sampling so
uh it'll be you know let's let's start
with um
remarks from you so maybe I don't know
who who would like to go first if Scott
do you want to do you want to start
things off and sure I can so uh so thank
you yancho uh it's a really nice talk
and I'm a really big fan of this result
uh you know I think it answers you know
one of the the big theoretical questions
that we had had about about random
circuit sampling
um so maybe it would be helpful to just
you know make some some brief remarks
about sort of the the history of this
right so uh
um you know like so so uh over a decade
ago I guess you know Alex archipov and I
proposed boson sampling and then you
know we uh um around 2014 or 2015 uh uh
um you know we uh Google became
interested in actually demonstrating uh
sampling based Quantum Supremacy but you
know it became clear that uh um you know
they were not going to do it with boson
sampling they were uh you know building
a 2d uh
um lattice of superconducting qubits and
so you know uh so our task would be to
sort of adapt uh the theory you know
that we developed to to to that setting
and you know and we said okay you know
that that's fine we can do that uh but
then um uh in uh 2016 uh it would have
been you know I learned about this work
by GAO and dwan right and and they uh
were making the point that well you know
if you have a constant rate of noise you
know on each gate which in practice you
will then you know random circuit
sampling is not going to scale right you
know you know or rather it will have uh
uh a a a a a a uh um in this sort of
regime that at least that that we had
been thinking about you know it will
have a a simulation that uh uh you know
it takes time polynomial and end and um
you know in our response at that time
you know this was this was six years ago
was uh okay fine we're not trying to
scale to arbitrary end you know we uh
we're trying to do something when n is
50 or 60 right or 70. uh where you know
like we so we fully acknowledge that if
if your goal was to scale to thousands
or millions of qubits then ultimately
you will need Quantum full tolerance
okay right and this and this this this
point came up in the in the Q a also
right uh and we said you know what what
is actually the goal with these random
circuit sampling experiments uh the goal
is um to you know do an experiment that
sort of directly shows you that you are
exploiting an enormous number of Hilbert
space dimensions for computational
benefit right so uh in the case of
Google Sycamore experiment it was a
Hilbert space with two to the 53
dimensions that's like nine quadrillion
okay and um yeah and as as was pointed
out in the Q a right we still do not
have a sort of
uh efficient classical spoof of that
experiment you know efficient in the
sense that it that number one it gets uh
uh it scores just as well on the The
Benchmark the so-called linear cross
entropy uh test and and number two uh it
does not require a large supercomputer
right you know actually just recently I
was uh
um interested to to try to do the you
know look up the the comparison right if
you look at the um the the the the the
the the best current classical
simulations of the of the Google
Sycamore experiment like by uh panchan
and Jang uh you know they they use you
know super computers that are um we're
probably you know using some some you
know megawatts of power or you know that
that that that that that's what you
would use if you wanted to simulate the
experiment in a similar amount of time
like you know minutes or or seconds or
whatever and so you know you can you
know you could say maybe the ultimate
resource here it's just how much money
are you spending for the electricity
right so you know the the uh uh
classical super computer you know is has
a lot of cores is using a lot of power
the quantum computer also has a dilution
refrigerator so that that uses a fair
amount of power as well okay but you
know the quantum computer wins I Believe
by a fact by some factor between a
hundred and a thousand okay so that that
that's that's kind of I would say the
current you know uh uh uh practical
situation in terms of you know spoofing
the the uh uh the the experiment um
now you know there is this uh uh a
beautiful recent work by you know Boaz
Barack and others uh
um there's this uh probably there's been
a previous uh Simon's colloquium about
but uh uh that that that work gives a
you know a a polynomial time algorithm
but it uh uh for for classically
simulating these RCS experiments but it
you know but but it it uh does not get a
linear cross-entropy score that is as
good as the score that Google got for
example right now it can only get about
10 of the uh the excess of of across
entropy uh that was observed in in the
experiment okay so it's like a a uh a a
signal at the 0.02 percent level rather
than 0.2 percent okay so uh so so I
think that that uh you know like you you
could say you know the the the the claim
of quantum Supremacy you know uh you
know
which was which was was never an
asymptotic claim from the beginning
right it was only ever a claim about
these specific numbers of qubits and so
forth right you know that claim is still
standing but it is standing more
precariously than many of us would like
okay it uh uh it is you know of enormous
interest now to try to uh do these
experiments with you know better
Fidelity which would you know allow you
to to to to to scale up higher and um
you know and of course to think of
better experiments as was mentioned in
the talk such as you know ideally
experiments were where we could
efficiently classically verify the
results uh so I do not regard Quantum
Supremacy as a done deal by any means
okay so uh
um uh but you know uh uh what what what
what what what this work does you know
as I would say you know like they're
even after the you know the the uh
Insight of GAO and dwan you know six
years ago uh it turns out that there
remained some little loopholes by which
okay maybe random circuit sampling could
have given not just uh practical Quantum
Supremacy but but scalable Supremacy so
for example there was the possibility
that it uh with random circuits of of
logarithmic depth uh that here you know
you'd be right in a sweet spot where uh
you know you would still have a signal
that you could observe that would be
like oh a one over polynomial in n
access in many across entropy you know
and yet
um
uh you know you you would also have nice
uh mixing properties and
anti-concentration and so forth so what
this work has done is that it is it is
it is it is killed that you know little
Lifeline you know by which Quantum you
know by which these experiments could
have been scalable which again was not
the claim that was made for them you
know in the first place but was kind of
like you know like it it it it it it it
it it it would have been an amazing
bonus if that had been true right and uh
uh uh so so now
um now now we now we know that that that
that bonus is not to be had and I think
it's extremely interesting to ask uh now
kind of you know is you know is there
any hope for you know uh let's say uh a
scalable speed up in you know the nisk
model of computation and you know until
a few months ago I would have been much
more hesitant to even say the nisk model
of computation like what do you even
mean by that right it's a it's it's just
a a practical term but there is this
beautiful recent work by uh Robert Wang
and by um uh um uh um Jordan Cotler and
others uh which has you know defined a
complexity class that they called nisk
which is somewhere in between BPP and
bqp right which basically captures what
you can do with a quantum computer with
a constant rate of noise you know on
every qubit at every time step combined
with a noiseless classical computer
um uh and and not allowing for adaptive
measurements so you know it seems like
you you know it is unclear you know if
you can do Quantum error correction in
this model okay they do give Oracle
evidence that this model you know you
know at least in the Black Box setting
you know can be more powerful than BPP
than classical computation but it's a
it's very very unclear how to
instantiate that Oracle okay and so now
the question that we could ask is you
know is there a real world problem you
know either a sampling problem a
relation problem or ideally maybe even a
decision problem uh that is in this in
this nisk class and that is not in BPP
right and uh so what what what uh uh you
know um you know the the work that young
child spoke about is you know you you
might say you know it is it is coming
close to ruling out random circuit
sampling as an example of that
separating problem except as he as he
alluded to in his talk there is still it
seems to me one loophole which is that
we could look at constant depth random
Quantum circuits which are not spatially
local okay and which have a constant
rate of Noise Okay uh these I uh as far
as I know we still do not know know of
any efficient classical simulation and
it is possible that you know even under
constant noise that these would still
give you uh Quantum sampling based
Quantum Supremacy in the limit as n gets
large okay of course
um you know there's a practical problem
you know that you would require very
non-vocal gates in order to implement it
okay nevertheless I now think it's
become extremely interesting to know
well you know is that really true is
there an efficient classical simulation
for uh you know just a a noisy random
you know constant depth Quantum circuits
um so that's so that's uh you know often
often you know one of the great benefits
of a new result is that it it brings you
know open problems into clearer focus
and I feel like that that is that is
what's happened in this case uh with
that problem
thanks uh great thanks uh thanks Scott
um uh Sergio do you have um we have uh
comments
yeah thank you um
yeah I I also like um this work
um
the main reason why I like it I guess is
well maybe different than what um to
emphasize in the presentation I think
um
so yeah the main reason why I like it is
that it shows that in what we call the
low noise regime
which is where the airport cycle is less
than once you don't have too many errors
um you know it's almost again in a very
kind of nice way which I think is kind
of fundamental that the computation
remains hard so the documentation is the
causes of computation is potential in
one over the noise and you know I don't
think that's I think that's quite
fundamental it is so very early on on
and the proof is just that the the
polyprus Decay is financially right in
in whatever the noise so you know that
that's what allows you to if you keep
the noise constant as you scale things
up you're going to get a polynomial
algorithm uh but before that
um you cannot cancel polypods and I
think it's
is you cannot cancel them for a
fundamental reason because that's where
you have like the design problem
basically you know the polypots are all
going to come
you know with different signs as they
would do with firemen parts or other you
know approximations the same problems
you know so sad with where quantum
mechanics is on play let's say
um so I don't think you're going to be
able to cancel poly paths that have
weighed uh you know lower than whatever
noise and I think you know that that's
kind of one feature that I I find very
interesting about this work how it shows
that in the Illinois regime you know you
still have the same problem and things
like that that does you know other
things break down if you try to go into
that regime even the discrete or a model
doesn't work anymore interestingly
chancho in in a previous paper also saw
that
um you know just things break down if
you have too much noise and in
particular noise of you know the error
per cycle is more than one but several
things break down and this paper is
another
way of of saying that you know why you
need to be in that regime as a Scott
said on the you know if you keep noise
constant and you scale up
um
yeah I think I mean in my mind I was not
expecting that to work I think we
brought that in 2016 when we introduced
the paper that you know complexity
Theory breaks down as far as I could
tell back
in the day
um we actually have a paper which we
call boundary of quantum Supremacy which
we make the same statement compared with
different algorithms and making some
approximations that you know classical
algorithms win if you just keep the nice
constant so that part I find you know
less intriguing but the other part I
think is very is a very nice
um yeah it's a very nice way to explain
why things remain hard on the learner's
regime and then
another thing in passing I guess I
understand why the algorithmic depth
you know it's interesting because maybe
there is a ray of Hope there there was a
real hope for things being polynomial
but that's for high random Gates
and the reason why you get a bias is
because you're using a random Gates if
you use the
okay
okay so the result is you know you can
sample something which is not the
uniform distribution even with noise if
the depth is logarithmic but in insert
of an experiment I guess like according
to that news model but and also this
algorithm but that's for high random
Gates and the reason why it's not
uniform is because you have these local
bias right you have these you know poly
pads that they are like one poly per
weight which basically means there is
like some local bias that it decreases
exponentially in depth and you can
capture these local bias because it's
local it's not like entanglement if you
use negates we're using the experiment
that entangled faster you will not have
these local bias so even at you know low
rate mcdaft in polynomial time you will
sample for from the uniform distribution
the local bias disappears I think that
is more a feature of high random Gates
than anything else is is just because
her random Gates don't mean entanglement
as fast as sort of the gates we find to
end in the experiment to a spread
entanglement faster
so sorry uh Sergio can I didn't quite
understand so are you saying that with
um with the specific gate set that
um that the convergence to uniform
happens faster or slower
faster
so so you cannot even have as much depth
so you get more noise uh so it becomes
it becomes um
so you have to have an even smaller
depth to get a signal is what you're
saying if you don't have a random
yeah these bias is just
I think it goes both ways you know why
you have a bias why
it's just
with our random
took you with her random Gates right you
can you can create like X into X I think
is one of the examples in your paper so
something I mean there is like some tiny
bias on the X direction or on the C
Direction and if you're doing two Cubit
or random Gates that bias disappears as
potentially in that but it's always
there
um so that means you're not converting
to uniform as fast
and so even when you have noise you
might have some signal which is not
uniform but but that's because it's you
know it's just a local bias you're not
entangling things as fast what you're
looking there is the thing that is not
being entangled it's just some local
correlation and in our gates the one we
use in the experiment which are you know
sort of optimized to spread entanglement
faster this doesn't happen so you
wouldn't have this bias even at low rate
big dams yeah
or another way to put it is if you
constrain yourself
you know in logarithmic depth
to a polynomial algorithm then your
algorithm will still sampled from the
uniform distribution
but the experiment will also convert
faster to uniform distribution so it's
all consistent
[Music]
great well thanks uh thanks Sergio uh
um
Adam do you do you have um yeah sure uh
I'm uh so first of all thanks uh Yoon
Chao for uh for a great talk and for the
wonderful comments from Scott and Sergio
uh I'll just add a few uh additional
comments you know so that there are
really a lot of different aspects of
this result that one can discuss but I
think you know it kind of gives us a few
different listen lessons to chew on as
kind of qualm complexity theorists
um the the first is that uh you know
kind of as a result of this paper you
know one needs to be very careful about
stating what asymptotic regime one is in
when one makes certain claims about
Quantum Advantage uh from certain
experiments so you know as we've seen
already you know sometimes we're making
non-asymtotic statements about 53 cubits
sometimes we're making asymptotic
statements about various sorts of noise
regimes and this kind needs to be very
carefully uh kind of uh kind of stated
in in kind of results going forward
especially since you know know a lot of
the prior evidence for hardness of RCs
is really in a very low noise regime
where there's a lot of signal in the
experiment like 99 signal and then
experiment as you scale uh as you scale
in whereas you know actually the
experiments are conducted in much much
higher noise regimes
um so that that's kind of one one nice
lesson I think we we should take from
this work
um a second thing is I think maybe it
invites us to reconsider some of our
intuition for hardness of RCs in the
first place so a lot of our you know a
lot of the complexity theoretic evidence
for hardness of RCs has its roots in
earlier work in Quantum complexity
theory on the hardness of quantum for
your sampling or for your fishing where
you know the problem is you're given a
random Black Box Boolean function f and
you want to sample heavy for your
coefficients from F and you know Scott
showed back in 2010 that at least in in
this relativized problem uh that that
this problem lies outside pH you know
one can view a lot of
uh you know both these results of of you
know about boson sampling and iqp and
RCS uh as trying to recover these
results in sort of a white box model and
one can also view this for your sampling
intuition as kind of the basis of
believing hardness of tasks like hog as
well like in some sense you know the you
know heavy output generation tasks for
random circuits is basically the exact
analog of for your fishing for for for
for random Boolean functions and you
know in some sense the the validity of
hog you know could could you know it
could be rested on cloth like like it
was in in Scott and Lee Jay's nice paper
on the topic but one could also think of
the intuition here as coming from the
fact of you know maybe viewing RCS as a
heuristic implementation of for your
sampling where you say well look you
know a random Boolean function has some
heavy outputs and light outputs
distributed and some kind of uh
exponential District attribution well
the outputs of a random Circuit look
something very similar there's some
slightly heavier ones some slightly
light ones and if you think this kind of
analog of a four-year Spectra of a
random function like if you think this
analog for RCS is extremely unstructured
in some sense that then you might
believe that this problem is hard and
what the result Yoon Chao talked about
as well as kind of Prior results of of
the gala doll result from 2021 that's
saying that actually random circuits uh
they're for your spectrum actually has a
a bit more structure to it particularly
in the low death regime so if you have
very low def circuits
um and you know in in some sense it's
easier to guess which Fourier
coefficients are heavy versus light than
it is for for a random Boolean function
so I think that this is kind of inviting
us to reconsider this and say okay well
you know in what depth regimes then is
you know is even uh what would we think
RCS is hard to sample even and then and
lowered voice use so I I think yeah I
think there are a lot of really nice
open problems that this that this work
brings up uh kind of in this direction
oh thanks thanks Adam those those are
great comments I'm really insightful
from from all of you it's um that's
really really interesting
um
any uh
maybe I can yeah yeah
so Scott mentioned this open problem of
sampling from a constant depth random
circuit
um so I think currently the complexity
of that problem is not known
even with for example a 3D architecture
but the problem here is that
there is a
sort of a complementary argument to
anti-concentration we're saying that if
we go below log debts then it's actually
highly concentrated in rather than just
being not anti-concentrated so which
means that if we just sample from a
constant depth random circuit the output
is highly concentrated and
that could bring several problems in
particular it would be one problem
inside would be hard to perform
statistical verification
and also one would intuitively expect
that if it's such is it is such heavily
concentrated maybe there could be some
way to simulate although
sure that technique still uh open
question and it's really you you I would
like to quickly interject that uh that's
kind of an architecture dependent
statement so uh yeah like for example if
you take certain depth architectures uh
like based on measurement based Quantum
Computing where you prepare a cluster
State and then measure in the you know
the very special basis that does
teleportation then one has
anti-concentration
um you know these circuits are not
simulable by the nap at all results
because they're considering just a
different circuit Ensemble
um so I that I think really this opens
up that there are a lot of different
architectures of low depth RCS one could
consider and the various fragments of
these statements are true or not true in
in different models of them and there's
like there's so I kind of view it's like
there's a whole landscape to kind of
sort out here so so can I ask a question
uh Adam so once you once you go to a
measurement based model then you're
relying on your input to be in time in a
certain way so is there is there natural
notion there of what it means to be
noisy in that case you know should we
start with a perfect uh initial State
and you know uh say brickwork say what
whatever you know and then then start
with a constant depth of uh noisy gate
so what would the fair model be then
well I I think the most realistic model
would be you have you have noise in the
preparation of the cluster State as well
so you you'll have them add all your
cuvettes and then you have no you know
those are noisy and then you have noisy
czs uh on them and then you perform
these noisy measurements right so
um and that I don't know how much is uh
known about about the complexity of this
of this exact of this exact model
because it's it's not a standard RCS
model because the Ensemble of
measurements you make is in the like hrz
of theta basis it's just this like one
parameter circle of measurements on the
Block sphere that you make in the
National Paper they're considering a
slightly different Ensemble where you
measure in the heart them on qubit basis
and the behavior of those circuits is
really really quite different actually
yeah I agree so I should clarify that my
earlier remark is entirely conditioned
Now using horrendum gates in the
constant app circuit surely mbqc is a
different problem
and one way to think about that it might
be to think of it as the effective
random circuit in a lower Dimension so
if we consider 2D RCS with mbqc then one
could study the complexity of the
effective OnePlus One drcs and maybe our
result could be applicable in that
context
okay and then Sergio mentioned this okay
sorry well
go ahead
okay so Sergio mentioned this very
interesting open question which is could
there be a family of random circuits for
which the convergence of to uniform is
faster than 2 to the minus D so I think
this is really open problem that is very
interesting and it will be really
interesting to study these type of
circuits and
the complexity of RCs with that
well I said with our gates is faster uh
I mean yeah I mean if you study them
using the techniques in your paper
so we did some of that in a paper and
information is scrambling on the
appendix we also work on the poly basis
uh
you know you're a laner and costly and
everything work on that you see on your
poly pads you don't have terms like x2x
ever which is what gives you the you
know exponentially gain that it always
always multiplies the police right the
police just keep multiplying because
that's kind of what yes more so then all
the parts you know even at lock and
depth if it's in a fully connector
architecture other parts will be
uh
having weight order and
yeah exactly so that's that's a very
interesting observation
um although I should clarify that uh
it's
um the information is scrambling in Gate
style is slightly different from the
2019 Quantum Supremacy gets that because
the quantum Supremacy gets that has
these continuous
epsteam Gates
that with different parameters and those
actually creates a bias for the polypath
in order to be extra exponentially small
in D so yeah so there's a slight
difference between the quantum Supremacy
experiment and the information is
probably expand of course it's very
interesting study was the complexity of
the type of circuits considered in the
in the scrambling experiments
yeah and then
Adam mentioned the um random Boolean
functions so clearly
hugely different from random circuits
because we
we sort of learned from our work is that
random circuits really have a lot of
structure if you look at how the gates
interact on top of each other and how
the how the depths place a role in the
poly paths so that's really
so clearly yeah I agree that one cannot
think about random circuits as random
warning functions
yeah in in some sense the the analogy is
that uh okay with a random Boolean
function you know all the entries are
plus or minus one and so kind of unless
you see a ton of the entries you have no
idea of this Fourier coefficient will be
heavier light but here kind of the
analogous quality is the Feynman pass
those are the things that are easy to
compute and somehow you're showing that
you're actually just looking at a few of
them only a few of them really matter
here uh particularly in the low death
regime but of course as the depth runs
then then this becomes less and less
structured so but again this is
crucially a statement about the noisy
regime right this is I mean I mean you
know if if we did uh for your fishing
but also with a constant rate of noise
right uh well you know it's not yeah
well you know exactly what we mean by
that because it's an irregular problem
but certainly if the or if the function
had to be computed by a circuit and each
gate in the circuit were subject to that
noise then then that would again become
easy to simulate right so so I think the
noise plays a crucial role you know I
wanted to say that you know one thing
that I'm not worried about at all here
is the choice of gate set you know I'll
just you know well you know I think we
you know let's just completely Grant the
assumption that the you know that the
the uh choice of gate set you know is
not going to matter you know I mean that
that that that that seems like a
technical problem to you know you know
maybe you know a worthwhile problem but
you know extend the result to the type
of game set that Google used in its
experiment you know let's just assume
that that can be done right I think the
real heart of the issue is about you
know sort of practical Quantum Supremacy
versus the asymptotic regime
um there seems to be
um some quite you know in the uh in the
chat that some questions from the
audience but uh for the panel so
do you want to speak up and say
oh so David is asking can we brainstorm
about what might be a new task where the
interplay between experiment and Theory
might strike
well I guess I can go ahead go ahead
all right I was going to say well one
was you know mentioned by John on the
tall which is trying to do something
which um for random circuit Supremacy as
experiments progressed
um that can be based on you know ideally
more like a stronger cryptographic
assumptions and where the verification
won't be won't require this is Financial
computational Resources as it does on
random Circle sampling or Boston
sampling or tasks like this
um so there's you know sort of an
interesting work in that direction and
yeah Hardware you know experiments keep
progressing the uh requirements for to
do an implementation also keep
decreasing so hopefully you know those
two things will meet
at some nearby point maybe in a few
years before we have a phone blown up
you know quantum computer with a ticket
Factory you know things like that so I
think that's very interesting and in
general you know in
nice guy guys while moving
uh
outside you know random circuit sampling
which might have applications in
Randomness generations and things like
that but maybe
on other applications which have more
can be of more interest like in physics
or something like that like trying to
see what
are problems
um of interest in some community that
maybe we can Implement in a quantum
computer like you know as some
observable for a interesting physics
problem that maybe we can you know
Implement on on a Quantum simulator
and then well the result was going to be
like this competition between classical
algorithms and and what we can do and
then you know on an experiment with
noise and things like that so I think
it's also interesting to you know keep a
studying those questions like making
them more Concrete in terms of well a
concrete proposal like here is an
observable for some problem that we can
maybe Implement you know in my case I
care about you know random
superconducting qubits sorry
um so they become a very interesting
controllable physics experiments right
um so what kind of problems can we try
to address with them that are interested
you know not just
from a computational point of view but
also that they give an unanswered on
interest in problem in Sumeria but at
the same time how do we know that
um you know it cannot be approximated by
a smart classical algorithms
yeah I'll just add that that you know
the thing that Yoon Chao already
mentioned about uh about trying to find
a cryptographic based uh you know
cryptographic proofs of quantum this
that might be feasible on kind of
intermediate scale device is is a really
nice question
um and it's you know it's it's really
not obvious uh whether or not it's
possible to do this kind of both from an
experimental side of you know can you
get X cubits or Y depth uh but but also
kind of from a theoretical side like
there's a wonderful question of like you
know do do any of these like lwe-based
proofs of quantum this would any of them
survive in an asymptotic regime uh with
constant noise rate that seems like that
it would be uh you know quite
challenging uh to to to get something
like that to work but if one we're able
to do that it would be extremely
interesting so
it's also something that Sergio just
mentioned which is um you know hinted at
which is this um this question you know
can one
can one use this this sort of uh you
know question these questions of quantum
Supremacy Quantum advantage to to
actually
um
uh explore new physics you know in the
sense that you know what does it take to
say here's here's some interesting
physics where one can make a
plausibility argument that this is
physics that would not have been
you know easy to compute you know and so
in a sense if it's new physics that you
know if it's not easy to compute we
couldn't have possibly explored it
before
you know before having this these kinds
of experiments because well we couldn't
have solved it in close form we could
have guessed at the solution we couldn't
have um simulated it on a classical
computer so you know has really a new
kind of physics so it's a yeah that that
might be something uh interesting to
think about
um
[Music]
um
so Sergio did you have did you have more
to say about that am I reading too much
into it or
um
well I don't know if I ever love to say
I mean of course people works on
approximation algorithms you have some
work on NPS you know the mid kind of
algorithm so which is specific to 1D
that gives us an idea that
uh you know what kind of problems in one
day we really it will be dangerous to
claim that we can do you know something
in an experiment that is not simulatable
because VMware is fairly powerful
algorithm in one of these and there are
versions to spending that to to the end
3D there is interesting work on that as
well
um so but that's just one direction
um there is the same problem which I
think shows up in in the worry that we
were discussing today again like the
polypas with a humming weightless I'm
you know uh one hour noise I think there
is a sign problem there so people you
know are aware that there is the same
problem generally speaking but uh you
know there there are probably other ways
to
think about it come up with problem you
know with reasons that problems are hard
to do
um to simulate classically and try to
make like concrete proposals that we can
implement
in in current noisy devices I guess we
have people working on it more and like
the you know in the physics team for
sure but yeah
yeah and in favor relay Direction you
know there are also great questions as
you know uh you know in in what sense is
RCS a useful Benchmark uh for for
experimental devices going forward that
is ours is getting a certain RCS score
really testing that you've made an
integrated Quantum device where you know
all the individual components that you
know work on their own that they're
actually all working uh together in some
sense actually the prior paper of of
gala gala doll from 2021 actually called
this into question perhaps even more uh
the than the paper that you Chow was
just talking about just because it in
that algorithm the way that you got a
non-trivial uh xev score was by just
chopping up the circuit into different
sub-regions and pretending the circuits
didn't even interact with one another in
the first place and this is really kind
of you know that that if that were to
happen your experimental device it would
be saying oh it really you know just did
not integrate you know some of your
qubit lines were just totally broken or
something like this uh so I think
there's also you know some nice
questions about you know our kind of uh
you know are are there algorithms that
challenge uh Quantum advancing you know
getting the you know Quantum Advantage
from low scores that look kind of like
physical processes that you would worry
might might be occurring in your
experimental device and you know the gal
the algorithm is an example of one of
these but I think it's a yeah it's a
nice question if there are more of these
out there
yeah interesting
um
any any other any other remarks or
thoughts
so um but thanks very much this is uh
this was very uh very stimulating very
interesting discussion thanks for all
your you know all your comments and
thanks you and share for the talks
um
and thank thanks to the audience for for
skipping the the soccer match which
which you can now hopefully resume and
you know a Brandon Aronson is playing
for the US you know that
uh don't tell me about that yeah it is
completely clobbering me in Google
search results
okay any relation uh no I don't think so
I mean if you go far back enough then
you know yeah
great yeah all right
okay all right see you all next week
yeah okay bye